حجمها يقارب حجم مبنى من طابقين ووزنها
يفوق وزن طائره ايرباص اي 380 محمره بجميع
ركبها
امامها ستشعر وكانك واقف بجانب جبل شامخ
انها اضخم شاحنه تسير على الطرقات في
العالم
[موسيقى]
عام 2013 الشركه البيلاروسيه احدثت ثوره
صناعيه في عالم الشاحنات وصدمت العالم
باعلانها عن شاحنه عملاقه كسرت قواعد
الفيزياء والميكانيك شاحنه ضخمه لدرجه
تفوق التوقعات
اطلقت الشركه على الشاحنه اسمها بلاز 75
710 يعادل طولها طول حافلتين عملاقتين
وقوتها تفوق قوه ست سيارات فورميلا 1
وتستطيع حمل ما يقارب 450 طن هذه الشاحنه
العملاقه دخلت الخدمه عام 2014 وكانت تنقل
الصخور في منجم للفحم في سيبيريا
[موسيقى]
تم تصميم شاحنات بلاس 75 710 لنقل الصخور
في ظروف التعدين القاسيه في المناجم
العميقه يمكن استخدام هذه الشاحنات ايضا
في بناء الهياكل الصناعيه والهيدروليكيه
الكبيره وانظمه الطرق السريعه
يبلغ ارتفاع الشاحنه ثمانيه فاصل اثنين
متر ولها ثمانيه ازواج من العجلات مقارنه
بالعدد المعتاد وهو سته وكل اطار يتحمل
وزن 102 طن وداخل هذا الوحش العملاق يوجد
محركان من سته عشره اسطوانه يعملان بنظام
نقل الحركه بالديزل والكهرباء وتصل قوه
المحركين الى 4000 حصان وعزم الدوران
للجاح يصل في ذروته الى سته الاف ومئتين
لكل نصف متر وهو ما يزيد باربع وعشرين مره
عن قدره محرك سياره الفورميا والعجيب انه
وبحجم هذا الجبل العملاق تستطيع الشاحنه
التحرك بسرعه 64 كيلو مترا في الساعه
تم تجهيز المعدات المصنعه لوحدات وانظمه
اضافيه تعمل على توسيع الوظائف وتحسين
جاذبيه التشغيليه هناك مجموعات المعدات
القياسيه والاختياريه تعتمد مجموعه معدات
على المنطقه المناخيه للعمل
عما سعر هذا الوحش العملاق فيصل الى سبعه
فاصله خمسه مليون دولار لكن باقتنائها
يمكن الاستغناء عن اسطول كبير من الشاحنات
في ميادين المناجم